all right welcome to another edition of
a beginner breakdown I am your host Mike
comer so today we'll be going over the
Italian game the reason why I picked
this today because yesterday was
Memorial Day why was a you know getting
a lot of glory protecting the chest
house killing snakes you see the picture
on my Twitter account at a big come s TL
and and then he go eating all the pork
steak my friend Adam Eubanks he just
doesn't get it okay he's at home eating
spaghetti
Memorial Day no barbecue for him so so
alright so I I didn't say hey ala show
them something about the Italian game
okay show them what it's all about
okay so so when the Italian game white
plays his King pawn up to black plays a
five white plays Knight to f3 black
plays Knight to c6 now you want to play
Bishop to c4 here because you want to
really hope right fingers crossed
date plays Knight f6 right which we're
allowing us to play the de fried liver
variation and we all know how great the
fried liver is okay but but they have
apparently been listen to my comment
right in this position there's only
three moves that are acceptable h6
Bishop e7 which both of those moves
prevent the knight from coming here or
you can play Bishop to c5 the Italian
game okay notice that the knight still
can't jump here and you know you'll see
this in kids game they little hop the
night there anyway and obviously it gets
taken okay so now we're in the Italian
and Bishop to c5 so there's a lot of
different ways you can play from here
you can play the move c3 that prepares
the move d4 you play Knight to c3
you can play d3 or you do my personal
favorite caps
right if you're in castle by move
forward you're definitely doing
something right all right ends up black
will play you know he could play it as
night out to f6 and attack our pawn or
play the move
d6 okay so when he plays d6 obviously
which piece that he just activate yeah
the bishop the problem Bishop you know
the bishop on c8 so where do you think
this Bishop would want to go yeah g4 pin
excellent so so if white just develops
normally like oh you activated my book
your bishop I'll activate my bishop well
guess what I'm going to g4 and this is
going to be a killer pin so then you're
going to play okay please take my pin
piece and he's like no way
and so he backs up and of course we
don't want to ever play g4 because of
you know you're removing the defenders
of your king okay so so that can be a
real big nuisance down there that bishop
as we've seen in some of the were Lopez
lectures you know he could even play
like if not in this instance but in some
cases in the world Lopez where you can
play h5 and just stop him but you know
Asia he would just go back and even if
you play g4 he would go back and then he
would just play h5 later okay so so okay
so we don't want that bishop to go to g4
right all right yeah all right Kyle's on
board at least we got one guy on board
so all right
all right we don't want that bishop to
go to g4 so what are we doing we just
play the knight back or h3 yes obviously
Age 3 excellent so after they play the
move d6 play the move h3 that's how I
want you guys to play uh the UH you know
the Italian gate okay that's the right
way and then and then you can just
develop normally you get your pawn
out your night out maybe he'll let you
know your bishop up in his night up on
g5 but if you're still not convinced
it's like what are you talking about
I'm not playing h3 I'll move five we'll
just see what happens when the white
player allows the pin to happen and
let's see how it goes okay so white
plays d4 e5 Knight f3 knight c6 Bishop
c4 Bishop c5 here alright and now white
proceeds with Knight to c3 he doesn't
get castled here and black plays Knight
f6 okay they're just developing so white
gets Castle black plays d6 so now
obviously everybody would know what to
play here h3 stopping the counter play
for black but okay so he plays d3 and
look at what black plays he knows he
knows so h6
rook e1 well he's still oblivious to the
fact of what's happening and now it
happened okay
and so his up and and so his knights in
a pin here so Bishop e3 attacks the
bishop bishop retreats so you know some
double pawns are good some are bad I
mean he can easily play d4 and these
guys might help each other out actually
and then you get that F file open so
he's like I don't I don't want to give
you those double pods but I'll take my
own yes August right right yeah in
hindsight he probably would have taken
with the rook but your rook is kind of a
major dummy up there I mean he's not
doing anything but it's alright but he
decides he's going to take double pawns
if white takes which it does you can't
resist the urge to give them double
pawns
so okay so he takes and now what white
plays move h3 now remember if you're
giving somebody a pin
the last thing you
to do is take the pin piece and because
it relieves all the pressure from the
position and if you do you make sure you
get some kind of profit for it there's
no real profit for this position so so
he just backs up okay so I capture pin
piece if for some how you're going to
get an advantage from the position if
you're not it's dubious all right so now
plays Bishop to d5 so and this is this
is he just takes it which is fine it
doubles up his pawns and now obviously
where does that Knight want to go to
he's got a juicy juicy spot here and
remember we don't want to capture pin
pieces we want to attack them we want to
keep piling on and it just so happens
the piece that is under attack for us
can attack the pin piece right okay so
so white can't take the knight because
he would lose the Queen alright so see
how well this pin is working out for a
black here so what would you even play
is white here there's not that any good
answer so he plays a rook III all right
so now's the time to strike you're going
to get a big long-term advantage by
capturing the pinned piece here okay so
so yeah so you could capture with the
knight or capture with the bishop
anybody let's let's here uh votes for
the Knight takes Knight check and it's
Shaq can't resist the check right yeah
you can't miss this let's check our who
likes just Bishop takes Knight anybody
Bensimon only or our producer Ben Simon
likes the wrong way okay
yeah so you get Knight takes Knight
check this is great
it takes back with the pawn and now we
are our Bishop just eyeing this on f3
here hahaha
so um he'll himself so he'll out all
right so now look at we did alright this
was way worth capturing the pin piece
right so you got double isolated pawns
on this F file you got this H pawn
looking goofy isolated and he's got a
big hole right in the castle so so now
we can just start marching right in
because nobody's going to stop us so
what's the obvious move here the Queen
g5 check you can't resist the check okay
so now hopefully you watch the last
class one of our last classes where you
know you could have a king just in the
corner where he's got no escape or he
can go where he's got plenty of room to
escape
so there's knowing that he plays King f1
alright so now black tries to get
another guy in the game if I was him I
would have got castled and then start a
start on my pawn storm okay so f5 so now
he's trying to break open the center
look that pawns in a pin so everybody
knows attack the pinned pieces and
that's why I should have canceled right
get out of that pin right and so now you
tax the rook rook moves so he's going to
attack it again but he's kind of he's
kind of missing the point here by not
castling he's letting like white get all
this counter play even though it's not
very good counter play but it's kind of
like like he really wanted to checkmate
White's King here but now he's kind of
diverting from that plan so rookie to
and he's going to go for a double attack
here so as their true things of a white
that maybe a black could attack and
they're both undefended direct house on
fire tonight the f1 age point yes with
Queen to h5 excellent and and it's still
and she's still protecting this D pawn
okay so she's doing a lot all right so
now he's marching and marching over
there and can't resist the take but now
white might get uh get some stuff going
here all right so so obviously white
should have taken the pawn here right
for sure all right but instead the King
the king is really scared the king sad
and he's crying as he does this this
march here that's what the king is doing
so now he said if you're not taking my
stuff guess what well he sees he sees
that you know he's got to gotta get
protect this it's alright so King to c1
and now you can start taking stuff again
all right so so notice that by not
playing h3 early on in the game you let
that Bishop get to h5 or g4 then at age
five and then it profited a bus it opens
castle for some the castle over there
manually again and you got two of his
pawns for that all right so now white
decides to be tricky here just rook to
d2 if you weren't paying attention you
might lose the game right because what
is under attack right now Steven you
know the answer the Queen yes there was
a discovery all right so you better do
something about that and now that was a
good time to think right it's like hey
guess what I'm up to pawns I have a
passed pawn this H pawn is passed
you know I'm doing great I have a easy
win if I just trade the Queens even
though black was technically on offense
there you know you might as well just
consolidate it down to a winning end
game and now you can deal with this pawn
finally alright so he protects it it's
fine
so pawn takes I think he takes with the
rook here I don't know a point punt take
might have been better but whatever
they're both fine
rook attacks the pawn so we should
defend it a lot of different ways we can
defend it but you know this guy is
really close to it so he gets the job so
Knight eetu attacking the pawn again so
we can just push it and attack the
knight now now he makes a big mistake
here okay where do you think we should
move that night we have different
options C 3 C 1 G 1 G 3 now so basically
we have four options obviously well we
could play there and that might actually
be the best move because then you're
into there but um but you want to keep
the pressure going because you're losing
right now so the last thing you want to
do even though it acts this pawn your
knight it only has one square to hop to
now h3 all right now who oh oh
in this position it was this rook that
moved alright so I mean nothing changing
the game but but now we can play some
Hope Chest right we can play rook to a
for threatening rook to a a check
so what move do you think we would do
here because obviously we don't want to
be skewered skewered is when it's rook
power piece another power piece and then
when we check the power piece as the
move and we take the other thing that's
a that's where the skewer is so so what
move do you think we should make here we
got King to b8 just rook over you know
protected or King to d7 came to these
seven was played we want the Kings in
the center so that's what was played
all right work a three attacks the pawn
which always asked why did why did they
do it and it attacks points we know he's
got two defenders
so what move do we got as black here any
ideas
excellent Bishop b4 you're protecting
and attacking dual-purpose move
excellent so why if you were smart you
would have played c4 unfortunately you
didn't he decided I'm going to attack
your Bishop as like okay I got stuff to
do anyway so he takes and and so now it
be three preparing c4
so now g5 and King up so now so now
black finally got the idea hey man I got
a passed pawn probably push it but now
White's got an idea I'm going to go for
well and not checkmate yet but try so
now he's see if your idea is like I want
to start checking and having fun up
there you should go straight to the
e-file but he can't resist a trick and
it's not really a trick he's got
rook on the D file the same line as the
bishop and then when he and then he's
not even gonna let him have a discovery
but but basically it would have gone
like this just working over here and
then his Bishop would be hanging but
he's having none of it
so he retreats prematurely here okay so
now so now then he's like okay I'm gonna
do my real idea anyway I'm not gonna
blow any time and now we can start
checking but let's see he decides he
doesn't even care you can check me you
get your one check-in it does nothing
but but in this in this position okay if
you're playing white which it was it was
a mistake for him to let this check
happen I mean all he has to play in this
position is rook here right and then you
can't get checked or even better would
be this rook that way because if you
play this rook then then white might
come up here so so let's see if we can
find a better idea for white then just
trade rooks and just lose anybody so we
doubled on the file so now Memorial we
want to double on the seventh rank right
right excellent
so we just move the rook and let's see
if this would go anywhere
we can't even play G whatever now I
don't know what you do let's just see
skips a move and then we play rook there
skips a move you know in this instance
it didn't do nothing
alright so but it's worth a try when he
trades rooks here
take take bishop attacks the rook rook
back
and and you notice in this position this
night get stuck you can't move it's
basically a worthless piece and this
isn't going to be very fun and now he
realizes he cannot stop h2 h1 so it
gives it up game over
resign okay so that's the Italian game
for you up and in this kids a kids other
game it's it's a different opening but
he falls to the same principle he allows
that Bishop to get to g4 and totally
ruin him okay so let's check this out so
white plays d4 d5 Knight f3 d6 this is
the Philidor so Bishop c4 and notice
just like in the last game black has no
problem just spending a move to play h6
that just kills all of a whites
counterplay here he can't put anything
on g5 now and that's where you know you
went a knight there bishop there anybody
but he's like nope and and you know he
never has to worry about being a
backward checkmated now because he's got
the left here all right so so Knight to
c3 Knight f6 doesn't have to worry about
the fried liver attack doesn't have to
worry about nothing
so white gets castle so so White's doing
pretty well except he's allowing this
bishop to come to a g4 Bishop e7 d3 and
now he realizes yeah I put my bishop on
g4 and it's going to be really tough for
you to do anything here so Bishop e3
again c6 prevents anybody from hopping
into a d5 here so now white plays h3
a little late right a little late so so
I never captured the pin piece Bishop h5
and now white decides you know if your
kings in the center I'm going to try to
blow open the center here so d4 he gets
a guy to protect it
rook to e1 and now he starts attacking
the bishop so so now where do you think
this Bishop can go he can you can
actually do something e to right and so
now so now this is a good way to try to
break up this pin if if you know you've
allowed it but look you just keep moving
backwards and backwards and backwards
Knight to a4 not really where you want
to be and he just used the threat you
know the tactic removing the defender so
what was that night doing so well on c3
that obviously it's no longer doing
defending me for so let's just take you
forth if we have an opportunity to take
material we should take it and not give
him a chance to protect it so so Bishop
to d3 so now he's ruined he's back in
the pin essentially Knight to f6 I'm
thinking it was this Knight
okay Queen to d2 all right so now yeah
well it was so so now you're like wow
you know if you're not thinking if you
were just thinking while my whole plan
is just you know get this a Bishop
Knight pin going and then as soon as you
know the you know we can't take back
with the Queen or the bishop and give
them double pawns let's do that
instantly but you got to look for better
moves all the time because we have a
tactic in this position that's even
better than destroying his King and
Mario can't find it so he's leaving okay
all right so hopefully Oh
we will lose any more people okay so
what more can we make - to punish white
in this position you fell for a really
silly tactic by playing all his pieces
so passively and jumbled up yes August
yeah pawn efore yes so now it's uh you
know you just got pawn for it yeah
pretty embarrassing to get pawn for it
right because it's almost that you have
to do it to yourself you have to put you
know your pieces on the same rank just a
square apart and it's like : so okay so
he retreats again and he takes d3 Queen
takes d3 attack the Queen why not Queen
here all right Queen to b3 why did he
play Queen to b3 any guesses to attack
the pawn right so so how would you
protect the pawn in this position or
doesn't even matter we're sure we just
Castle and just let them have the point
it was like who cares no we want to keep
our all our material keep keep keep the
material trust me so so you know the
best protectors of pawns are other pawns
right because you know our queen and
rook they want to do cool things right
not just you know maybe sit upon right
so instead you know we're seeing this a
lot in these games where where people
are playing the sub optical moves and
and they know they're suboptimal moves
but they just can't resist hey like he
plays d5 creating a hole in his position
one all in hopes that oh he won't see
that I'm protecting it okay so if you
play like that you know you're just
going to weaken weak and weak in your
position until it collapses with the
otoscope chess all right so Bishop the
d2
all right he's going to defend with the
rook and now look what happens here
Bishop to f4 and so now okay
the rook has got to go or at the b7 and
now which piece of flax is in a pin
right now the bishop right what are we
supposed to do the pin pieces all right
who can attack the bishop here the other
bishop excellent
now black only has one saving move if
you can't find it well excellent it's a
lie now that I look I look deeper at the
position now that now that I they're
doing all these discoveries on me now I
can see discovered protection but I
missed it totally missed it before but
um but black even has a better move than
than that then the discovered protection
anybody have any ideas because the
threat is huge
it's a Bishop takes Bishop takes Bishop
is the threat file by Bishop takes
Knight check yeah Knight e4 excellent so
it's it's forcing the issue it's forcing
him to take this but maybe maybe it
maybe that is maybe uh I don't like it
either right right right right so so I
guess the discovered protection was the
best let's check out with the computer
so my guess is Knight to b6 yeah
yeah all right Knight b6 is the winner
yes makes me feel good so now how do I
go back control - all right we're back
all right so my my my guess was the best
move
just for the record okay record show all
right so anyway so 94 was played and up
yeah you take the bishop queen takes and
guess what the pins still happening and
it's just at a different piece now
so f3 attack the pin piece so black
finally gets castle a takes D takes so
now black has a passed pawn alright so
so what are the best pieces you went
behind the if you're playing white okay
and you don't want this pawn shoving
down your throat here who's the best
player to get behind the pawn the Queen
the rook or the night the night
excellent Knights are the best at
blocking a passed pawns great job
because they can still like do cool
stuff whereas these guys not really
alright so instead you got he's got the
Queen of Queen on e3 they're up okay
well yeah if you get if you would get
the night the night here by via f1 here
you see he can still like like snatch
stuff like if he puts his Bishop to f5
if he can just snatch it off and he's
still like and if that pawn pushes you
can just go ahead and take it then or go
right back there so he's still being
like a menace you can still like give
give checks potentially and do all kinds
of great stuff that's why you want the
knight blockading the pawns so so in
this in this instance Knight f1 would be
the best move followed by Knight to e3
okay so Queen e3 and now it allows f5 to
be played so Nina goes back for the
check always check and so now he blacks
so now back to e3 all right and Knight
f6 here c3 attacks the pawn Knight to d5
coming to d2 pond c3 Knight c3 I love
these games where you see this a lot
like black is obviously like crushing
white here right everybody agree with
that I mean if you had to play this game
out you would think blacks easily going
to win and you see this so often where
where two guys are playing and one just
destroying the other for the whole game
okay but then but then pen they make one
big mistake and it's like oh well if
that didn't happen I would have I would
have crushed you know but uh that's
that's unfortunate how they the game
ended a head ah he didn't see that that
the knight was in a pin there and uh
that was it but I mean he was going to
lose anyway just it's just expedited the
process you know all right I saved the
best for last
on accident I guess you guys are lucky
so late arrival been fangled
just for you just for you okay so we're
going to go over the Italian game so
here's our last Italian game it might be
a repeat I can't remember this might be
the first game we show all right efore
e5 Knight f3 knight c6 Bishop c4 Bishop
c5 Knight to c3 d6
all right so now everybody knows what
the play here h3 excellent excellent
okay instead d3 and he's really going to
he's really going to feel the burn this
time so Castle Queen to d7 Bishop g5
attacking nothing but preventing the
long castle I guess alright so so now
it's too easy almost what are we
supposed to play here
okay in this position it is black to
move he just played Bishop g5 dubious
alright but so what what's been our
whole strategy for black the whole time
right to implement that pin
now we implemented the pin we don't just
want to rest on our laurels right we
want to make that pin profitable right
90 40 I'll tack the pin piece can't be
any easier so now h3 yeah a little late
buddy a little late and so so now what
move would we play obviously yep because
it's check right don't you know you now
now you want a pawn you broke open his
castle I don't want to look at the other
variation I don't want to look this is
great this is the easiest way to win so
now rook e1 and now attacks the bishop
but that almost helps them play a little
defense here Bishop h4 Knight to e7 so
what is the last move you think you
would play here you need this Bishop to
become a big-time defender so when
you're on defense right sometimes it is
okay to trade but in this instance I
don't know maybe it was afraid the
knight was going to go here and here but
Bishop takes not good Queen takes c7 so
yeah here comes g5 so he sees
our queen check this way better all
right so check and then make so so he
sees it so he stops it with Queen to d2
so now it will just play Queen to f6
threatening Queen to g6 is there
anything we can do to stop it here I'm
guessing no Knight II - right right
obviously I spice Queen check Knight
pretends to block it right but he's
faked because it's in up the pawn is in
up in and then everybody sees checkmate
here yes Martin okay well yeah I could
move the edge - yeah yeah yeah well I
can't I can't move days so move the h2
now what yeah it's just good defense
good defense I don't know what I do here
all right I take the thing and thread
and checkmate huh
yeah oh right in your face barn he
that's you yep
try to stop this now you can't you can't
all right you're on the clock I'm
threatening to crush your queen here
Queen e2 right who's only more in should
be suggesting moves like hello man all
right here it comes a check which one's
the best check pi ones mate and the
others not
that didn't work you don't want to do
that it's a trick it's a bishop check oh
and then games over right obviously
stop it check them again all right I
just have so much material yeah yeah
just just take it and then be all let's
save our bishop finally I offer more
trades you know and then we're the best
okay I got the pass H Quan okay yes
anything's better than what happened
right oh yeah yeah yeah okay so so here
we go here we go here's the moment of
truth
Oh because because a queen was attacking
the pawn through an x-ray interesting
way down yeah right
not even bargain the master of Defense
over here could stop it yep all right
so Ben Feingold who would have guessed
it right again hey you guessed it - OH
oh yeah how's it going all right so
we'll see the real end of the game so
instead of Knight to e2 he goes Queen to
e2
and then Queen g5 check King h1 and that
the checkmate for the game so that's the
Italian game hopefully you all know how
to play it if you play as the white
pieces don't hesitate to play h3 be
happy put slam it and put an exclamation
mark next to it okay because it's that
good it'll save you from getting your
castle busted and all this checkmate
shenanigans okay
you